[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are
currently off the record we have with us
today mr silent mike hey
with my mister thank you for being here
silent mike good sir thank you team
thank you glad to be back
mr quiet mike i don't know you're a
mister you're yeah you're a big strong
guy though too oh when do you turn to
mister i'm about to be 34 dude
wow
i forgot i was 34. you feel weird when
you go to like a store or something
right and then like you're like oh do
you know where like whatever it is and
they're like oh i'll help you sir and
the guy's like 70. yeah i'm like that's
weird right because does that make you
feel superior like i'm a man now not at
all that just makes you feel like the
customer feels like it's good
on this it feels like it's good service
can't say certain service dude yeah
i feel like it's good service but then
the guy when he's like 70 i'm like
i should be calling you sir what would
you rather him call you you could still
call himself while he calls you sir yeah
son son that's really nice yeah that's
what a father figure slightly
condescending son can be condescending i
have a bad habit of calling people kid
but i just mean it whatever you're like
new you're a kid yeah like that kid
yeah that kid was whatever and
are you from the east coast of
sacramento yeah
yeah
east coast of sacramento
yeah
i'm trying to draw sacramento my head
i like american customer service because
it's like every day you know we lie to
ourselves that we're actually like free
and independent when we're all peasants
right but when we go into a store that's
a moment in time when you can feel like
a king and it's okay
don't you don't think that a hierarchy
you don't think they treat you like a
king in many other countries better than
america oh actually they yeah a lot of
countries have great customers way
better have you been to france if you go
to france right and you like you take a
shirt and you unfold it well no i don't
want it and you could do the the
customary walmart thing we're just
taking just throw it on the side don't
come and don't make sure the wrong
fold it back you never ask them hey can
you fill up this water and then they
look at you like the [ __ ] is wrong with
you this is hong kong i think there's a
difference between their customer
service versus our customers
that's very true i think our customers
are just like anything in this japanese
store in japan oh god they treat it's
not even a king they take you out the
store and then they put in the bag and
then they give it to you outside the
store
does it feel more real what i don't like
is in a lot of american places it feels
so fake don't call me sir or thank you
or you're like saying thank you as like
you're not even looking at me like yeah
man thanks for coming oh thanks for
coming to walmart
yeah yeah you're the door welcomer we
have welcomers and they don't give a
[ __ ] about you just go [ __ ] zoomies yeah
it's always zoomies you're just gonna
steal some of cyrus's anyways
that's the backflip
because like asia's like it's so
obedient
you can't tell if it's coming from their
heart or if they're doing a good job or
they're gonna get killed or something
yeah yeah
it's right here dude you know so like
the department store dictator subject
relationship in asia it's not so much
king yeah like the elevators in taiwan
right in the department stores
there's a elevator like flight attendant
oh yeah yeah it's like a chick right
with like the [ __ ] lace on the eyes
and like the [ __ ] like little derby
hat and like [ __ ]
like a suit i like bar trying to get all
small yeah and it's a little dary
she'll step outside of the elevator she
goes first floor
and then she'll go in and you don't
you're not allowed to touch the buttons
which floor would you like they have
that here
whatever [ __ ] macy's not in l.a
like a hotel or like i feel like new
york has a lot of that [ __ ] no i'm gonna
talk about a fancy place
to be asian [ __ ] when they're doing
that yeah
fourth floor do you say it's in china
taiwan
have a safe [ __ ] flight away
but you know what's cool is if they
actually have a transatlantic accent
when they're saying yeah go honky on you
regular department store
that has like eight floors or whatever
or more it'd be like that yeah what
would we don't even have that they do
such a good job that you're like
is this coming from your heart or right
the elevator all [ __ ] day huh well
they just don't have rights like us yeah
so their citizens are more like
you know what
let me treat this person like a king or
else you know so i could feed my family
and kids well that's like the uh social
credit deal um i'm kind of about it
about it tell me nothing bro
i never heard a white guy say that
you're a fan of social credit well like
if like uh if you're an [ __ ] and this
isn't how it's gonna work obviously but
if you're a dick i think you shouldn't
be able to buy a house i don't care what
you get but if you're an [ __ ] [ __ ]
you yeah be a nice guy
that's what i'm saying we can't regulate
all this this isn't my what are silent
mike's measures yeah this is my euphoria
yeah what are your metrics what about a
yelp review on a human being so like
that kind of isn't that that black
mirror episode though a little bit right
oh yeah because the social media likes
is like yeah it's like somebody like
kind of barely rubs you off the wrong
way it's like i'm gonna down like you
and then suddenly it's like you know
perpetually only brings me here like
every three months because i got less
followers than you yep you get recharged
if i have more followers i'll probably
be here once again i'm telling you i'm
like get your follower up and then i'll
bring you one more yeah i'm trying i
think they talk about
followers to buy a house though yeah
don't know about followers but i think
morals should dig into it you know and
that obviously gets hairy right because
then we got religion in the state and
that didn't work out well in rome you
know yeah
it could be simple
the moral followers ratio no yeah i
don't think this is applicable to
sacramento
we're wives out there
well what about the current credit score
are you a fan of that no
transunion fan what what i didn't know
fico scores how about that bus station
small talk yeah what are you my cpa what
do you think of that
[Applause]
kind of experience
i love credit scoring isn't that [ __ ]
only like 30 years old i didn't know
that
oh yeah yeah like american credit scores
yeah really because before it wasn't so
credit heavy yeah we we
when the banking system got credit crazy
that's when our economy also skyrocketed
because it also used to be on the gold
standard and a lot of you know great
depression peoples
they just saved and they didn't spend
and they didn't use credit
great depression was pretty whack bro
yeah they had no credit bro they had no
credit score i literally think that 80s
credit score concepts in the near future
then
they're trying right the social one
right yeah i think that's i think they
said china right trying to china has
something like that let's do social
credit yeah but i don't know how that
works it's not by being nice it's not it
should be it should be nice i just
talked about this yesterday the idea
that like in other countries when they
have like a single nation or single
ethnicity it's a lot easier to do things
like that yeah like a man yeah that's
what hitler thought as well
well yes
and they had great systems though they
beat them crazy follow the rules i guess
during that time i feel like in china
it's easier not just because the people
are the same because there's less white
people there that too there's more
people there's already been a culture of
like
let's compare our kids
my kid sucks how about yours your kids
sucks too oh they're both kind of sucky
they've been like you're in the culture
being raided all the time uh whereas i
don't know if like
aside from [ __ ] those dog
competitions i don't know if we have a
raiding culture
in america yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
start going on dates start picking
people up started like lengthening them
that's pretty good that's one wonderful
border collie [ __ ]
because in asian culture if you're tall
or if you're short or you're fat or
skinny that's you like look my study's
so [ __ ] fat all day so yeah they pull
the punches man
fat critic in america that might work
like an obesity a bmi
people would lose their [ __ ] before
people will lose their [ __ ] they'll
storm the capital for that did you guys
see that [ __ ] recently or
i don't know if those sports illustrated
or whatever but maybe it was cosmo but
they had an obese girl in a bikini and
they're like this is the new healthy
or some [ __ ] like that it was i was not
according to nice or thick because those
are different slim thick yeah i mean she
looked like she had high cholesterol
dick is still kind of hot yeah i mean
i mean well i mean skinny people can
have high quality
looks but i mean
there is there is blood pressure
she's looking a little purple
superpower she looks like there's like
some arteries clogged but you know what
like
there's a i mean if you look at if you
look at like generally right you can you
you can tell like if anorexia is one
curve and then like um obesity is on the
other like you know that either or is
obviously unhealthy but now they're
using that word um healthy and attaching
it to obesity and then like if you say
anything otherwise then you're fat
phobic right so i'm like what the [ __ ]
dude weird i think they're just lowering
the bar of healthy and they're bringing
it down i'm not yeah i'm not afraid of
fat people i just think they're fat like
yeah you ain't scared you're just fat
but
i don't really know how to talk to them
we can't really relate can't look them
in the eye
i've been fat before like yeah same here
it's not like
it was a choice kind of right it's like
a [ __ ] see-saw with them you're like
i just i can't [ __ ] get on the same
level as you man because when i when i
got overweight right like i was getting
sleep apnea i was having problems with
[ __ ] breathing my heart would go
crazy like
yeah like it was it was healthy baby
yeah i mean like living it up man i'm
like how can you how can you put that on
the front cover and lie to people and
say this is the new head today's video
is brought to you by upstar nothing is
more discouraging than paying down your
credit card and barely making a debt in
your debt that's why upstart is here to
help you pay off your debt quickly so
you can finally get ahead upstart is the
fast and easy way to pay off your debt
with a personal loan all online whether
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a million people have
used upstart to get one fixed monthly
payment upstart knows you're more than
just your credit score and is expanding
access to affordable credit unlike other
lenders upstart considers your current
income and employment to find you a
smarter rate for your loan with a
five-minute rate check you can see your
rate up front for loans from one
thousand dollars up to fifty thousand
dollars and receive your funds as fast
as one business day after accepting your
loan find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com off the record that's
upstart.com off the record and don't
forget to use our url to let them know
that we set you loan amounts will be
determined based off your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application go to
upstart.com off the record
i think
i think it's cool to be like this is
fine yeah but i don't think it's the new
healthy like i don't think we should
like be mean to people but i don't think
we should [ __ ] exalt them i think
america america's been so bad though
because you were healthy maybe gained
some weight and then lost weight i think
america is so fat they've been fat their
whole life they don't know what good
feels like yeah so they don't know like
you notice like damn bro my throat's dry
i must have been storing all night or
damn these stairs are hella hard to get
up their stairs been hard to get up
since in third grade that's true
dude obesity i think the rate is still
50 for even kids and that's obesity
that's not overweight that's not fat
that's not that's like over here you got
most obese country or nation in the
world let's do it uh
china's coming up it's not u.s though
it's not u.s right not u.s i heard
china's coming up it's like there's like
nine polynesian countries and then it's
like some other yeah trying to make
sense they got a lot of money like
things were rolling i don't think the
polynesian islands are accounting for
it it's got some economy some countries
is um
it's due to american influence though
oh yeah yeah cause when you see all the
old photos of like
like the islanders
to me they don't look like the rock
you know what i mean like a lot of
steroids going on in that one yeah i
mean but then like when i think of
polynesian i think of seven foot dudes
that are like 300 pounds yeah i'll tell
you all and there's not one guy
so we just had a standard for dean on
our podcast and his wife is samoan and
he goes if you go to isamore versus west
salmon and i think westeros one that has
a us influence there's a huge like the
heights the same right but one is
regular maybe like a six foot 170 guy
the other one is the 300 pound there's a
government cheese processed food it's
just so one is brother is fast food
somewhere over the rainbow yeah
give me your best what are they what's
it called what's the uh uh the language
or the accent
a pigeon do give it to me oh dude i
gotta practice mine dude i saw this dude
on tick tock and i really don't laugh
out loud a lot of stuff this kid killed
it so hard and i was just just dying
bro dying [ __ ] laughing i don't know
why i thought it was the funniest thing
i've ever seen better than rob schneider
here's the top ten all right the top ten
most obese countries nauru cook islands
palau marshall islands tuvalu
tonga samoa kiribati micronesia and then
kuwait is number 11 u.s is number 12.
wow
i'm surprised by kuwait in there yeah
who would have thought what it is what
year is that now this is 2022 yeah i
wonder i
can't go back per capita concept you
know what i mean that's crazy that
surprises me that's really surprising
yeah but if you're in hawaii though it's
hard
to not get fat because the food is so
good every day bro every time i go i
gained 20 pounds and then the the
portions it's like going to [ __ ] a
diner here like
it's like this big
jumper just a whole cake
it's just like honey i shrunk the kid
[ __ ] food it's just huge the
mozzarella sticks everything is claim
jumpers police batons
claims numbers of macadamia nuts on it
it sounds good though but
that's hawaiian food
it's so funny because
summed it up have you noticed like in
hawaii you're either super [ __ ]
athletic or you're like
massive yeah or maybe that's just what i
see because it's like they're [ __ ]
happy i know all right
survival they're just like i hear
hawaii's been ranked like one of the top
healthiest states in in the us probably
[ __ ] mentally healthy i mean
california is yeah which is crazy cause
you still sleep healthy yeah
is it because of just like the
the people that come here health
vloggers yeah whether it's like uh
hollywood industry it's like fitness
industry you know what i mean like
coasts always do better because your
chances are gonna be slightly more naked
i think it's access to food because i
remember going out to the midwest and
whatever
there's so many like there's so many
cities of just or like even towns where
it's just chain restaurants yeah yeah
yeah you've been in ohio yeah my dad's
from cleveland bro that's all i was
shocked dude i was like what the [ __ ]
this is like idiocracy man yeah bro i
thought
mcdonald's here i'm like damn i'm you
can eat good but damn it might be
different now i remember going to visit
family as a kid and like vegetables that
were like in season that's all you could
get
oh true that's so stupid growing up in
california it may sound stupid to people
listening but like in sacramento you get
a strawberry year round yeah over there
you're like it ain't strawberry season
no strawberry to be found
that kind of makes a lot of sense 100
billion percent yeah they have sex over
there there they don't yeah no sex
because you need to bust out the
strawberries for this oh we got
valentine's yeah changing
okay
now we know how he courts geo to bed
we got some strawberries
[Laughter]
i'm going to uber eat some strawberries
in the house always in 90s r b music
video
there's rose petals everywhere in his
house genuine songs and [ __ ] so so i
think where did we come from from this
is it because um social credit and fat
people does that mean that i want fat
credit
and that's kind of crazy i might get
some hate you know it's fat streaming
but i think that if you're healthier
you're probably better for the society
and giving back because i'm more
functional
you know we did this you guys should get
some benefits we read this article we're
in japan so like uh
you know a lot of like people they
strive to get jobs that have sick health
insurance like sick benefits right but
in japan uh they have a rule where it's
like you have to meet me halfway so the
health insurance only qualifies if
you're a 38 waist and below 38 still
kind of big so yeah so
wow
right they gave you some leeway but if
you
through your own personal habits get
above 38 then for them it's like why am
i ensuring your health oh yeah if you're
not contributing to your own health our
life insurance is a little bit like that
you and i were talking about it like i
was trying to get a life insurance
policy when i was uh in my early 20s
because it was super cheap my dad passed
and they're trying to figure it out and
like uh i'm the thick dude and so they
wouldn't give it to me they're like oh
bro you're too fat i'm like 23. like
there's no way right and so then i had
to do like blood work and they came and
measured my waist versus my shoulders
and my arms and like the agent was super
dope she's like all convinced i'm like
don't worry this data will show where
you fall were you fun at i mean fat at
that time or were you lifting yeah i'm
still lifting good yeah do all you guys
have life insurance i do now i think i
do yeah [ __ ] no i don't even know why i
got it who the hell am i going to give
it to you
i'll give it to you bro yeah i got
nobody else
when you're married you should have one
yeah
but it's funny when they try to find
like what your habits are to see like
what it would cost yeah yeah yeah they
talk to you you're like what about it i
didn't tell him anything you can lie
right you smoke
pretty uh depressed you okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're all riding uh
how often you go skydiving
not cigarettes no
just a little crack
it all contributes to your premium
though like if you have risky behavior
then it's like yeah motorcycle i think
you own a boat all day really
yeah i'll be like i just pose on them
and then i won't tell them i actually
have one it's just for instagram yeah
don't write it you said instagram
yeah yeah
higher premium
you know what sucks though is that um so
the reason why it is so [ __ ] fat
right is because
it's it's over correction the reason why
there's so many fat people in america is
because of over correction because
during the great depression everyone's
starving and then we got refrigerators
they had to figure out methods of how to
make food accessible high calorie rich
dense
shelf lasting food and then they went
and looked at subsidizing farms for
wheat corn all these things that can
have a long shelf life and then we had
grocery stores and things like that and
with that now we have a huge um if like
an infrastructure that supports this uh
uh like i guess food economy where like
if you look at grocery stores over 50 of
that is like long-lasting shelf life
foods right those tend to be big-time
preservatives and stuff basically that
will make you obese and also we don't
have in this country like um like
basically like in europe and uk
there's there's a rule on how much sugar
you're allowed to put on each item
we had a lot of sugar i thought you're
going to say churro
we have a rule
we don't have that in the u.s because uh
you know sugar is addictive and it's
good so we can put as much as we want so
that adds to the obesity and then also
the infrastructure of how u.s cities are
built it makes it very hard to burn
calories because like look at how easy
it is in japan or europe or wherever
where it's a pedestrian kind of
infrastructure where you could walk
outside you could walk around
and it made a lot more sense too because
you know
my girlfriend is from london so when she
came here she's like i can't [ __ ]
walk and she goes i need to walk like i
just gained 15 pounds or some [ __ ] and
i'm like she can walk it's just going to
be like 30 miles a day and like weird
right like the views are probably
different you're not walking to the
store you got to walk like three miles
it depends on where you live right like
you you can't walk yeah but it's
dangerous you just got like where are
you gonna work into the parking lot
let's take the stairs yeah spark out
americana and go to the [ __ ] uh other
mall dude you go to the malls in the
morning like santa anita you're gonna be
hiking off dude well it's not even that
it's just like you just see old asian
people just walk around the mall like
you see a chinese mom and make up your
own exercises
they walk around like this i go yeah
i saw this lady [ __ ] doing this while
she was walking up dynamite
honestly
if you don't move you lose it i mean
it's true it's true it's pretty good
we're gonna all be doing that soon
i do it sometimes all the time like in
between these videos we sit down all day
we gotta get up that's what we do
door walks that's why we do them for
fitness
burns
it's a cultural thing it's a cultural
thing
we gotta go out there today and [ __ ]
do the asian grandma walk
making up our own exercises those uh you
know those random workout machines that
they've been putting at the parks and
stuff you know that's useful yeah bro
maybe during
there's an outdoor park uh in between my
gym and my house and people were
smashing that thing there so many people
you're talking about like [ __ ] bar
stars
they're pulling them up yeah
like they don't look like that but
they're trying yeah they're trying no
black poles yet they all look like
johnny bravo though huh
their legs look like two
spongebob sticks
just doing chin-ups all day that's
backstabber yeah
[Music]
bye
[Music]